are cancer cure statistics accurate? Well, we don't have any statistics, you know that.
From a medical legal standpoint, we can't keep track of statistics. Medical
cancer cure statistics, I go over this in detail in my book, but you statistic
through the American Medical Association with cancer is based upon the date of diagnosis.
So if I was diagnosed in 2020, April of 2020 with cancer, if I lived till April,
second, 2025, the better, how, you know, the quality of my life in those five years,
if I live one day after the five-year date of diagnosis goes by, I'm put down as a statistic
of cured. So that's how those statistics work. And you could say that those are really rubber
numbers, they are. You could say that that's really an unfair way to do things. It is, but
it's very difficult to clarify that. I mean, how do you say somebody is cured of cancer? Well,
when they don't have, you know, anything, will they have no evidence of disease on a PET scan?
When they have no evidence of disease on an MRI or CT scan, you know, that's one way,
but, you know, then a year later, no, they have metastasis and they have evidence of disease,
because a PET scan and an MRI CT scan, you know, they're not going to show cancer,
unless it's over three million cells large. So it doesn't mean they don't have cancer still.
That's why I say don't stop using your right, don't stop doing your therapies.
But so how do you, how do you define that in the medical industry? Those that you can't really
define it that way. So we're just going to go based upon whether you live five years post-diagnosis.
And of course, the problems with that is that you could have lived a horrible life,
but you die one day afterwards and they still put you down as cured. Now, the other
website of that is that if you don't go through their, their portal, if you don't stay in contact
with your, with an oncologist, if you kind of stepped out of that field and you're doing alternative
things, how they keep you track of anybody. So are they just a sous vide that you live five years
and they're putting you down as cured? I don't know. I don't know where this is being kept track of.
I don't know of any portal that exists. I've never seen it in writing where an oncologist is supposed
to keep track of the date of diagnosis and the five years later. I don't think that exists. I don't
think there's a nationwide medical portal site that is time-based tracking date of diagnosed five
years later if that person is still alive. Quite honestly, I don't think that exists, which makes me think
that a lot of these numbers are kind of made up. And especially if you don't choose to do standards
of care, how do they even know if you're limited or not? What are they doing? They've got a nurse
looking at obituaries every day. I don't think so. So how is any of these statistics even kept up?
We have people that contact us. We haven't heard from them for 10 years and they contact us out of
the blue. We have to start off this conversation that we have to explain to them, hey, now we have a
member site. You need to get on this and this happens every week almost and that Marine is literally
having to get a person on the member site that you know they haven't contacted us for years. We didn't
even know if they were still around. And that's okay because we're not trying to create this dependency
on us. We want you to be independent and really we want to be interdependent so that you do have us as
a resource when you need us but we're not trying to create a unhealthy dependence then you have to
stay in contact with us. So we want people to be educated and feel like they could go off on their
own. It's got an email yesterday from somebody who we haven't heard from since he started three and
a half years ago. So it's that's okay you know but how would the medical field know and keep those
statistics? I just don't think they just don't think it actually happened so no that's that's a
long answer for are they? Are these statistics reliable?